- They're trying to put the
internet back in the box.
I'm trying to make DRock the most famous.
I've turned him into a
fuckin' verb and noun.
- You've got your perspective.
(crowd cheers)
("Go Hard" by Via CJ)
One thing to think about on that
is how I think about
micro and macro, right?
So to me, what I love, is
like I hate the middle.
Right?
I'd rather sell a $900 soda
or a nine-cent soda, right?
Just like, that's what the internet's
actually doing to our society.
Do not be in the middle.
Be in the super duper premium
or be in the like high, right?
So that's how I think about leadership.
- [Female] Mediocre middle.
- What I like about this media play,
and what I do, is it's super macro.
Like all my employees at scale,
could know quite about me,
I can bring a lot of value,
like there's unlimited content.
19 meaningful pieces of content a day.
You know you could, and I'm
unbelievably back to the luxury
I have of being an entrepreneur.
Super transparent.
But then like today,
I had like 16 one-on-one meetings already.
Like, and to me it's
like don't do the middle.
Like, make content at scale
internally, like at scale.
Like the struggles you went
through, I mean, you know.
And it's always association
whether it's like,
what happens when you start
a family as an executive.
You know, based on knowing
enough about big companies,
I would be absurd about
your two and three,
because that is the decision
point for seven years
or two points and that's
the vulnerability.
You don't get those returns
if they don't stay for seven years.
And then micro.
Like for you two, like I couldn't,
couldn't push senior
players that matter more
on one-on-one or one-on-seven
random breakfast, drinks,
dinners, it just matters.
And at this level, at
this size of a company,
you're so damn busy,
the opportunity to go
have drinks with four gals
that look like you that are
in year two is almost never.
And so like, you know, I
mean a lot of the scrutiny
I take from my own senior executives
is doing that kind of work,
but I just don't think they understand
what I call gray value.
(deep piano music)
The best attributes are that
it's where the attention is,
and the media product on it
is disproportionately inexpensive.
To me, I'm just very simple.
Is the attention properly priced,
overpriced, or underpriced?
So for me, as a marketer
and a businessman,
the best part about it is,
it's disproportionately underpriced.
Like, uncomfortably.
Like I'm looking at my taxes
to figure out how I can spend
more money on Instagram ads
for anything I care about
whether that's selling sneakers,
or wine, or getting my content seen.
What's worse about it is,
it's so popular,
it becomes the mirror
of human shortcomings.
Social media hasn't changed us.
It's exposed us.
So everybody wants to blame social media.
Social media didn't make you
the PR agent of yourself.
You've always been.
You just used to do that at
work, or at the coffee shop,
or at the PTA meeting.
So I don't think there's a worst,
other than what I know people think
is the worst part about it.
But it has nothing to do with Instagram.
It has to do with 70 years of prosperity.
That's what's happening in America.
We're able to worry about dumb shit.
(upbeat techno music)
Hi!
- [Rachel] Hello!
- Hello!
- Rachel.
- Nice to meet you!
- So nice to meet you.
- Neha.
- What a treat!
- Nice to meet you.
- How are you guys?
- Good, how are you?
- Sit.
- [Rachel] We're hoping to like,
- Smart.
- [Rachel] maybe build a
career-oriented labor model.
- Have you thought about
building their brands,
even though that creates
a vulnerability for you?
- [Rachel] Building the brands
that we're working with?
- No.
- [Neha] We as statisticians.
- [Rachel] Oh, we've thought a
lot about that, we've had to,
- Can I give you a huge piece of advice?
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- You should disproportionately
try to make them famous.
- [Rachel] So we talk a lot
about how there are movie stars,
- You should disproportionately
try to make them famous.
The number one mistakes
that all these companies
are making right now,
in exercise, in everything else,
is they're scared to let
them build their brands
because then they have
leverage and then they leave.
- [Rachel] They don't all leave.
- Of course not.
And more importantly, if you're
known for building brands,
they'll all come to you.
You'll have a pipeline greater
than the people that leave.
- [Neha] That's so smart.
- Like you should almost literally build
an internal agency of personal
brands for these people.
It will become a singular
point of leverage
for you in your industry.
- [Rachel] Yeah. I think we're
committed to that for sure.
We're really excited
about hiring our sponsors.
- I really, really can't stress it enough.
- [Rachel] 'kay. It's all up to you.
- The second you, with 59
God damn Instagram followers,
but with press 'cause you've launched,
show post three, this is Karen,
here's her story, we love her,
every other industry professional
looks at that and be like,
my place would never do that.
- [Rachel] Make 'em excited.
Yeah, and then they retain clients also.
- Yeah and listen, a bunch will
leave and do it personally.
I'm just telling you.
That's firm.
Not as much in the net result.
- [Rachel] Right, exactly.
- It's the number one mistake
that every single professional service,
like prior to, kind of like
companies, making right now,
they're trying to put the
internet back in the box.
I'm trying to make DRock the most famous.
I've turned him into a
fuckin' verb and noun.
(heavy techno music)